[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT KUBIS: Hi.
I'm Robert Kubis.
And I'd like to introduce
you to Google Cloud
Spanner, a fully managed
relational database service.
Cloud Spanner functions just
like a traditional database,
except that it's
horizontal scalable,
while still providing ACID
transactions and SQL semantics.
And we don't give any
performance up for that.
Now, this is important
because if you have ever
deployed a global
multi-regional database,
you know that there are
certain steps from configuring
machines, setting up
replication, and failover,
and design your sharding.
And keeping all of that running
can be a challenge, too.
While you may not encounter
all these challenges today,
knowing that you don't have
to worry about them while you
cross various scalability
boundaries in the future
will give you a great
deal of peace of mind.
To give you a picture of just
how amazing Cloud Spanner is,
let me start by showing you
how easy it is to get started.
With Cloud Spanner,
we turn all that chaos
that I just talked
about into one screen.
You just name the instance,
choose single or multi-region--
we pick Europe West here--
and how many nodes you want.
I pick 42, because that is
always the right answer.
We click Create,
and in seconds we
have a distributed
database at our disposal.
But let's talk about a
more practical example.
Imagine you are a ticket
seller selling tickets
to events worldwide.
It's pretty important that you
only sell each ticket once,
that buyers experience a
high-performance website,
and that everyone sees
the same ticket inventory.
For this example,
we have deployed
Cloud Spanner in three Google
regions, US, Europe, and Asia,
all connected by our
really high-performant
private global network.
We are running
workloads that emulate
customers buying billions of
tickets for one million events.
Here's the schema
of our application.
You see tables with columns
that can be joined together,
just like in any other
relational database.
There are significant numbers of
rows for some of those tables,
so this is a really large
relational database.
In our demo app, each
purchase transaction
involves a complex mix
of reads of multiple rows
from and writes to
many of these tables.
We are checking the
availability of tickets,
fetching account information,
and update ticket owners
and calendars.
We can even run SQL queries
against this database
while it's handling
all that load.
In the Google Cloud
Developer Console,
you can find the query
entry under your database.
In our case here, we are
looking at a query that
checks the availability of
tickets on May 12th at 7:00
PM in Germany, all without
blocking those critical buy
transactions that are
happening all around the world.
What's important here
is what you don't see
and how unremarkable
this SQL looks like.
There's no additional complexity
in the query from a sharding
system.
There's no need to join
across multiple shards
of your database or
anything you like.
With Spanner, you can just
simply undust your SQL skills
and put them to work again
on a massive, scalable,
horizontally-distributed
database.
And to help you
optimize your queries,
you have the possibility
to inspect the query plan
before or after
running your query,
right in the Developer Console.
Now real world applications
and workloads change over time,
and your database needs to
adjust while your business
keeps running.
Cloud Spanner lets you make
transactional consistent schema
updates with no downtime at all.
You can simply add
or change columns
while your workload is running.
And what happens
if your app grows
and you need to add capacity?
With traditional
systems, you have
to figure out how
to scale up, get
an even more powerful server,
and upgrade the hardware.
Or you can try to
scale out, but that
involves lots of
complexity, middleware,
and adds operational
risk, and takes time.
In Cloud Spanner, I go
to the Developer Console,
edit my instance, add more
nodes, and click Save.
That's it.
That's the power of a
fully-managed, horizontally
scalable SQL database.
And of course, since we
designed Spanner at Google
to scale with our
business, we made
sure it can handle
very large databases.
Let's switch over to our
monitoring tool, Stackdriver.
The graphs show the history
of our demo database.
And there are a couple of
things to point out here.
First, in the upper
right, you will
see that when we
set up the database,
we were able to load data
at over 800 megabytes
per second sustainable.
That even peaked at around
1 gigabyte per second.
That's just crazy fast, right?
Second, you can see,
on the lower left,
we run the whole demo
against a database
that is over 80 terabyte
of logical data.
Let's recap.
You can create a highly
reliable, performant,
fully-managed, multi-regional
database in seconds.
Cloud Spanner is a
relational database
with the power of SQL
and ACID transactions
plus advanced features like
versioning, strong consistency
and online schema changes.
You can scale out and in
as needed, fully managed,
and you don't have to
worry about replication.
Your system even automatically
tunes itself for performance.
And last, but not least, Cloud
Spanner is built for scale.
Google has been running the
largest operational dataset
on it globally for years.
Check out Cloud Spanner today
and find more information,
like best practices and
case studies of Spanner,
on cloud.google.com/spanner.
[MUSIC PLAYING]